Alright so, now that we have a handle on what it means
to compute a best response against some finite state strategy. Let's actually
take a look at these. So, so this is a quiz. Imagine
that we have a gamma that is large, so greater than a six.
>> Mm-hm.
>> What is the best response to each of these
strategies? So this will be a quiz, but let me just
make it clear what the, the goal of the quiz
is. So, if you're, if you are playing against, always cooperate.
Which of these is the best response to it, which of these is
going to actually have maximum reward?
If we're playing against always defect which
is going to have maximum reward? And if we're playing against tit for tat
which are going to have maximum reward? Any
questions about that, does that make sense?
>> I'm just making certain I have the rows and
the columns right. So my opponent is playing on the rows.
>> Yep.
>> And so I'm choosing among the columns for each one of those rows. Yes?
>> Yeah. So I labelled it best
possible response for the columns. And these
are the opponent's strategies on the rows.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, go.